peu
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
bon
on
[Applaudissements]
je suis le premier du pape je représente
la chrétienté et toute sa puissance
depuis des siècles des hommes se sont
battus égorgés pour me prendre ou me
récuser
dieu sait combien de cadavres j'ai pu
voir autour de moi mais jamais autant
qu'en cette époque extravagantes où
fleurissaient le sens dorée des borgia
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 14 185 l'homme dont je supportais le
poids n'était pas un borgias trouvés
lancé cardinaux les textes
rodrigo borgia avait cinq enfants dont
l'un s'appelait lucrèce et l'autre ces
dames un beau jour de cette même année
il va les arracher à leur mère et les
conduisit chez dounia dry un ami la une
de ses anciennes maîtresses pour
qu'elles parachèvent leur éducation
[Musique]
oh
et à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
[Musique]
on
je ne peux pas dormir j'ai peur césar tu
ne dois pas avoir peur il n'y a aucune
raison
je suis ton frère il y avait moi il ne
t'arrivera rien je le sais mais j'ai
peur malgré tout tu vas voir on va faire
un pacte de sang tous les deux tu sais
ce que c'est c'est comme un serment
m
[Musique]
pendant que ses enfants devenaient
expert en grec en broderie ou à l'épée
et que surtout il devenait indispensable
l'un à l'autre leur père lui voulait me
conquérir devenir l'intendant d'un
suzerain nommé dieu un suivre un idéal
puisque lui orial savez dieu ne
reviendrait jamais
votre frère aîné pedro luiz est mort et
bien dans ce cas je ne vais plus devenir
cardinal quel bonheur je te voyais
vraiment pas cardinal assieds toi
lucrèce à mélusine mais toi genou et
demande moi partout tu as fait un an que
je vous observe
je ne sais vous êtes deux bêtes sauvages
non je ne mettrai pas à genoux je suis
prévost d'adp je suis chanoine de
valence archidiacre d ati vas tu ne te
relèveras quand tu auras un plot raymond
parent tôt
je vous demande humblement pardon madame
maintenant je me vois obligé d'avertir
votre père on ne peut plus vous laisser
ensemble il faut à tout prix vous c'est
paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelques années plus tard une hausse en
huit mon possesseurs du moment en train
en agonie même pour un pape il s'avérait
difficile de mourir en paix voir en état
de grâce
le saint père a besoin de sang et de
sang frais du sang humain
oui si vous voulez qu'il revienne lui et
lui faut absolument du sang
il faut ferrite n'ayez pas peur et
petits enfants
on ne vous fera pas mal
ça ça vous avez fait ça vous avez fait
ça je n'aurais pas fait ça mes propres
enfants ou ceux de la boue rouge
lui même n'a pas pu boire ses enfants
ces animaux égorgés pourquoi pour rien
est ce qu'au moins au milieu des
immondices vous avez songé à donner les
derniers sacrements à ses enfants
j'avais le devoir de sauver notre saint
père le pape mais moi je vous dis que
pour sauver un corps tu ne pouvais plus
l'être vous avez envoyé trois petites
samedi dos santos à en faire sans les
derniers sacrements
mais vous prétendez encore vouloir être
pas tenez demandé à sa sainteté
je sent innocent elle a vomi je vous le
dis en lui faisant boire ce sens dont
elle ne voulait pas c'est vous qui
l'avez tué kw agents tos invités je suis
là
le papy mort n'est pas figé
[Musique]
où
ans
à
j'étais donc liban chargé de me choisir
un successeur 23 cardinaux pratiquement
mur est vivant selon la coutume se
décidèrent vite leurs 11 août 14 192
il revint à l'air libre et le cardinal
rodrigo borgia fut nommé pape sous le
nom d'alexandre 6 il avait atteint son
but il était convenu
mais à peine était il arrivé jusqu'à moi
qu il s'évanouit
je pensais en moi même c'est mauvais
signe et je ne me trompais pas quelques
jours plus tard j'ai eu la joie de
connaître sa famille
il y avait là ses deux fils jouant et
geoffrey qui arrivait d'espagne où il
avait été élevé il y avait à mes pieds
julie farnese sa maîtresse qui arrivait
d'une fort noble famille et il y avait
lucrèce qui arrivait de son couvent mais
pour que la famille soit au complet
il manquait encore quelqu'un capitaine
voilà mon homme le plus fidèle le
seigneur michelotto il aura accès à
toutes les portes du palais ne vous
inquiétez pas de son masque michelotto a
eu une grave maladie
attends moi là
vous êtes en retard comme d'habitude mon
fils
julie je te présente césar mon fils aîné
césar je te présente julie mon épouse
spiritueux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on voit la victoire
e
[Musique]
vous ne vous êtes pas vu depuis combien
de temps d'accord cette place
asseyez-vous
[Musique]
il s'agit de renouer nos alliances avec
la france et de mater cette italie qui
s'énerve kiné merde je n'ai pas pris ce
trône pour faire le pantin rome avec une
tiare n'est pour servir la messe ni pour
me promener sur une ânesse en robe
blanche le jour de pâques
j'ai pris ce trône parce que j'aime le
pouvoir je connais très peu
chacun d'entre vous mais vous ne
m'intéressait que dans la mesure où vous
m'aiderez vous êtes jeune encore des
brouhahas rien sans doute pour l'heure
je ne peux que vous marier comme vous
dites ces choses pour vous marier il
faut faire acte de chair et oeuvres de
chair toi le grès tu très belle
d'ailleurs tu épouses race for the same
assurera la paix à milan toi je ferais
tu voudras ce anciens d'aragon ça va sur
la peur d'espagne toi césar tu seras
cardinal quant à 3 juin
quant à toi mon fils je trouverai une
alliance à l'étranger et maintenant
buvons à votre bonheur qu'elle
automatique tutelle a pas ton cheval
noir
il est vraiment il accrochable regarde
mais oui je suis les médecins c'est
normal qu'ils le sentent
et là nous faire que tu dire ne soit pas
lâche qu'elles ont peur de nous je sais
bien que je vais venir avec toi comme
autrefois
nous ne sommes plus les enfants césar
quand je t'ai vu tout à l'heure en
entrant c'était fou c'était tellement
thouars est tellement plus toi je sais
qu'il rentrait comme en région et puis
tu devenu pâle très pâle
je suis pas l'eau si maintenant je ne
vois pas dans le noir mais je n'en
entends tu le bruit de mon coeur je n'ai
jamais eu aussi peur même pas ta
première maîtresse mais attends promet
durera pas plus que toi ta première
tapisserie ou et ont premièrement ce
n'était que des cérémonies
c'est vrai
seulement
des cérémonies
qu'est ce que c'est ce soir tout tout ce
que tu voudras la seule chose la seule
attente ce repas qui n'en finissait plus
je tremble
tu es glacé
tu n'as pas peur toi non
j'avais peur de ne pas te reconnaître
plutôt rencontrés et que tu es rentré
j'ai su
le regard m'a fait mal à la couche
[Musique]
du coup
m
c'est drôle si tu pense que nous y ont
été faits l'un pour l'autre
il n'y aura jamais un autre homme dans
ma vie une autre femme dans la tienne
nous aurions pu être pieux en amour et
fidèle dans le mariage et nous ne
l'avons pas le droit français nous
serons bientôt les deux êtres humains
les plus épiés de cette ville et il
faudra que nous soyons le plus secret
puisqu'il est honteux d'aimer son frère
rien et honteux là on n'existe que si on
les prouve et je n'ai pas honte de toi
ni de moi je suis fier de ta beauté de
ton esprit ton corps et quand je te
tiens dans mes bras je suis fier de
penser que c'est le même sang qui va
dans ton coeur et dans le mien et moi je
suis fier que tu sois si beau c'est
intraitable et si ambitieux déjà il me
faudra passer à travers bien des
comédies et des mensonges et des
meurtres
je reviendrai vers toi a couvert de sang
jeffrey peur à tout le monde
es tu sûr que je ne ferais jamais peur à
toi non tu ne prends pas peur aurait
peut-être
mais l'horreur est un sentiment physique
il suffira que tu me touches pour que
l'horreur se transforme en autre chose
je tape sûrs et en tout césar non pas
parce que je ne peux pas faire autrement
mais parce que je ne veux pas faire
autrement
lucrèce tu es le seul lien réel que j'ai
avec les autres avec la vie je suis
parfaitement enchaîné à toi mais c'est
étrange je me sens libre vraiment libre
que lorsque tu m'en garde il lâché envie
d'agir et que veux tu à part toi je veux
l'italie je veux unifier gouverner le
pop italien entend moins bien le
gouverner pour son bonheur ça t'étonne
non pendant que tu te cupra de l'italie
actuelle moi je m'occuperai de l'italie
à venir te dire que penses-tu qu'il
restera de toi de charlot 8 de tous les
princes tous les deux de ce pays dans
100 ou 200 ans
rien aussi peut-être un ou deux et en
revanche quand on parlera de deux
petites chaînes l'idée de prendre illico
de palestrina tout le monde saura qui
sait tout le monde rendra grâce à
l'italie tu es amoureux de la force de
l'italie césar et moi je le suis de sa
beauté
oui nous allons faire de ce pays le pays
le plus beau le plus puissant et le plus
gay du monde entier et rien ne nous
séparera jamais ni thé mariage ni mes
conquêtes à nîmes et enquête ni thé
mariage
à propos tu assistes ramon prochain
oui mais si ce forza est jeune et beau
je le tuerais
lustres c'est mieux
voulez vous prendrez prenez vous pour
femmes est légitime épouse
l'illustrent dame lucrèce borgia ici
présentes et promettez-vous de la
traiter comme votre épouse et votre
femme légitime solveur de bonne volonté
et vous illustre dames le crès voulez
vous prendrez prenez vous pour légitime
et oui marie l'illustrent ses dires
giovanni ce ford ici présents et le
considérer comme marié pour les jt je
l'avais
et
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
d'accord
ans
[Musique]
k
oui
ouais
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
où
et
[Musique]
où
les enfants sont venus
ils sont beaux ces parts et moi ils sont
encore plus basses on verra
que tu dis
on dirait pas un frère et une soeur en
les voyant mais le conte jack on est
bien tiré plutôt des amants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les français arrivent
c'est immonde rôle il a persuadé charles
vite tous les attaques et les tripes
altima 30 de mes premières r oui
n'oubliez pas que vous êtes pape
pourquoi ne pas nous réfugier au château
saint-ange les français ont plus de mal
à prendre une forteresse qu'un palais
des princes au nous allons nous réfugier
au château saint-ange manille j'y serai
plus à l'abri
c'est bien voilà pourquoi est-ce que je
vous plais ne rien faire
[Musique]
et puis je vous donner un conseil
un conseil encore demain accroché le
saint suaire la muraille du château
charlot 8 et superstitieux et proposez
moi en otage il m'emmènera dans ses
bagages et croyez moi ça ne rassurera
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis heureux que nos négociations est
abouti nous partirons demain
vous n'avez plus besoin de cet ep vous
êtes sous notre protection
j'en suis convaincu
si votre majesté d'un vérifier les gages
de notre bonne foi
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien très très bien
vous permettez
voulez-vous que nous vérifions les
autres non non je me suis recherché les
sacs recharger les sacs
c'est les pieds oui le français va
hurler et alors tu te figure borgia sera
là pour l'entendre fini par s'échapper
je me demandais ce que tu faisais mais
j'étais très surveillé tout ça dis-moi
soir n'est pas là non mais non je
l'avais promis et tu trempé
ça regarde moi dans quel état tu iv
j'aimerais bien voir la tête de
charleville
il doit être fou de rage on était
presque à me à la fin je vais lui
manquait toi aussi tu m'as manqué
j'en avais assez de courir pas un homme
en mon absence qui me l'avait juré
mais ce n'est pas anna bâ aubertois
césar vous êtes de retour
quelle joie vous faites des visites bien
nocturne richard besser
qu'est ce que tu veux elle avec son
petit garçon et moi sans toi on
s'ennuyait un bon c'est ça
[Musique]
le père aviez vous je vous en veux mais
tu m'ennuie geoffrey dorne mois qui sait
a été licencié dans la chambre d'une
grèce tu as l césar et antoine de chars
le 8
je suis juste la poche jure que c'est
vrai père je tuerai ce [ __ ] enfants ne
nous laisseraient jamais dormir en paix
le début mais ça enfants sont d'une part
la touche pas c'est la femme de ton
frère mais celle là de l'autre côté
c'est ta soeur mais je ne vais jamais
oublier non plus tu le défi je te dire
ça j'ai une bonne idée de te nommé
cardinal du confrère
qu'est ce que tu aimes tant les jupes
autant que tu restes le temps c'est juan
qui se rêve en pologne et qui dirigeants
béarnais vous n'avez pas le droit je
tourne des droits je suis pas tu es tu
toi je te le dis tu seras cardinal toute
ta vie toi du crès tu vas rejoindre son
mari ils te conduire à des poses toi
sans siens tu vas qu'on sonne et celui
qui pleure tout seul dans sa chambre
pendant finissent est un enfant
[Musique]
je crois que l'on a tous besoin
mon dieu quelle horreur
quelle malchance c'est pas grave pour
toi te reste qu'à attendre que ton mari
grandissent mais moi cardinal toute la
vie jamais il est vrai que tu n'es pas
fait pour la chasteté saison d'ailleurs
ce serait dommage dis moi tu ne manque
pas de sang froid
cet incident ne t'a pas troublé s'il m'a
troublé mais j'aime la colère les éclats
de voir les baisers et les drames
d'ailleurs je n'aime que ça ma mère
disait que si je n'étais pas né d'aragon
j'y serai la plus grande fuite air du
royaume sa mère n'avait pas tort
c'est une riche nature peut-être
pourrait-elle nous servir il croit
qu'elle plaît à jouer
c'est bien possible il ne me déplairait
pas ce jour elle pourrait même nous
servir de pièges vaniteux comme il est
et si je joue les amoureux fou vis-à-vis
d'elle il n'aura de cesse de vouloir me
la prendre comme il a pris mes charges
et mon grand tu lui est suffisamment
il va falloir perd vite il n'y a que ce
petit geoffrey qui ne m'appelez pas
décidément il me faudra un alibi à toute
épreuve il est gardée jour et nuit il se
méfie de tout le monde comme tous les
lâches
dieu merci et sa vanité était à la
hauteur de sa acheter et c'est comme ça
et par elle que je l'aurais je t'aiderai
à la convaincre ce ne sera pas difficile
j'aimerais mieux encore le père quand
tout petits au frais maintenant il va
falloir que tu nous écoutes sancya fais
toi dieu tout puissant que le reptile tu
pourrais pas dormir alexandre jeu ça m
c'est bien le moment de dormir
je le dis avec toi je viens de la
chambre de but laisse je ferai des
raisons mes enfants choisis pour vous tu
le savais parfaitement depuis toujours
c'est pas nouveau et qui as tu trouvé
celle très bizarre bonfils leurs cheveux
c'est impossible
il est prisonnier de charles et huit
prisonniers sous serment qui plus est il
ne l'est plus s'est enfui sais même pas
ce que c'est que le mot serment comment
les clôtures que tu ne les as pas élevé
du tout tu les a fait élever par
d'autres tu ne t'es même pas donné la
peine d'aller voir des enfants pendant
15 ans alors que j'étais dans la chambre
de lucrèce l'amour
ce n'est pas nous qui payons les leur
reprocher je te répète qu'ils sont frère
et soeur et que l'ins s est incliné puni
par dieu un dieu encore dieu mais
pourquoi tu ne peux pas dire un mot sans
parler de dieu et ce n'est pas tout il y
avait l'ancien avec eux sans ciani mais
bien comme alexandre fait froid et
comment est-elle jeu les très jolies de
bourse
ça n'est pas encore un peu de
consistance mais ne sais pas si un jour
elle devait être un spectacle pas
désagréable ils sont tellement pour tous
les trois
cette blonde air avec ces deux pauvres
ou césar n'est pas mal c'est mon fils
et oui c'est mon fils mon fils je suis
père de betty monde des animaux qui
savent même pas reconnaître l'odeur de
leur propre sang je mis au monde des
monstres quoi et je suis pas je
représente dieu sur se taire
tu m'écoutes gelé ou qu'est ce que tu
disais que je suis le représentant de
dieu sur cette terre au mondial exxon
si tu pouvais te voir le représentant du
christ en chemise de nuit père en
faisait trop beau pour être vrai
pour petit adduction de l'enfant
[Rires]
[Musique]
je
oui donc votre épaule qui je fais il
doit vous cherché partout et ça fait dix
jours que mon frère l'archevêque que
vous dévore des yeux et vous laisser
faire et point il est vraiment si
séduisant aussi séduisante on le dit à
rome c'est un homme d'église
ce n'est pas un seul là ça veut dire que
ce n'est pas un séducteur
qu'est ce que vous appelez à séducteur
dans ce sens là peut-être en effet
soulever votre main ils voulaient pas
payer aux deux frères le petit jouet la
balle et le gros me déplaît je n'aime
pas césar il n'a même pas non plus c'est
pas là pour vous servir de vengeance je
n'ai pas à me venger de césar j'ai la
préséance sur lui leur tous les domaines
dans tous les domaines sauf ma mort ok
ça ma couronne mais c'est d'autant plus
plus douloureux qu'avec ou sans césar je
vous suivrai partout
ne savez vous pas
je me plaisir que je vous ai vu ce soir
tribales j'en ai pensé qu à vous sentir
une petite maison au bord du tibre
mais en secret ils ont voulu vivre avant
il faudra mettre fidèles secret car dans
cette condition je ferai de vous la main
le plus comblé de ses deux mains
non
voir
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cernes ou avoir la garantie 6 mois
[Musique]
pourquoi m'as tu choisis moi parce que
toi aussi tu choisi des hommes que tu ne
prends que ce que tu veux
[Musique]
que tu élis pourquoi tu aimes les gens
libres jeu même que ça quel est ton nom
les tessières son vrai nom je m'appelle
l'italie mais vitaly n'existe pas il ya
florence naples venise mais il n'ya pas
l'italie j'ignore la ville d'où je viens
je ne suis qu italiennes
c'est pour ça que tu ne me connaîtra
jamais on verra bien
il est vraiment délicieuse ce breuvage
comment le préparer
c'est une recette comment apprise ma
nourrice espagnol il y à des herbes du
vin de l'alcool et de l'est les bords
ça un peu le goût d'opium aussi mais en
tout cas je suis sûr que cette
aphrodisiaques
[Applaudissements]
quel est le motif de cette tapisserie le
martyre de saint sébastien
cette chose là est ce que c'est ça c'est
une pêche et début d'une flèche
tu es en retard
que faisais tu ou mais tu es jaloux
s'est réfugié à l'usagé bien de jalousie
au pardon tu as apporté à bois non je
n'y ai pas pensé mais tu as besoin de ça
pour mai mais n'ont certes non mais
j'adore cette boisson et à rome tu es la
seule à savoir la préparer mais tu
trembles tu es jolie qu'est ce que tu
m'as me sens à ma vie je me sens pas
bien du tout
mais que fait-elle vois tu cette saute
capable de s'enticher de juin mais non
elle n'aime personne d'autre qu'elle
même essentielle paul de son corps cela
me scandalise mme toi scandalisés mais
oui baraquements je comprends très bien
que l'on soit fan du corps d'un autre je
le comprends même trop bien
lucrèce si je deviens fou il marche de
long en large il sait qu'en lui même il
tape sur les murs mais qu'est ce que tu
mets dans ce vin de l'opium vraiment je
ne sais plus quoi faire de lui
depuis combien de temps là tu ce vrai
c'est vrai tu parles du vin évidemment
depuis quatre jours mais il est horrible
à voir et dangereux il n'est plus maître
de lui il finira par me frapper me
défiguré cette plaisanterie devient
odieuse tu as pitié de lui
pitié non j'ai peur pourquoi pitié il
est grand beau et bête n'a rien à voir
avec césar césar n'est ce pas si nerveux
rigueur sens qu'il ya deux minutes il a
fait tomber la tapisserie et ma chaise
on va presque que les âmes sont brutaux
c'est juste
pardonnez-moi à toutes les deux tu as
raison essentielle cette plaisanterie ne
peut plus durer
demain soir tu vas lui donner
rendez-vous dans la maison du tibre toi
tu te rendras le matin et tu prépares à
deux verres sur la table dans chaque
verre tu mettras une triple dose ça le
remettra d'aplomb ensuite tu rentres est
une bouge plus et avant le coucher du
soleil
il faut que nous soyons tous les trois
autour de notre père
[Musique]
at
elle a plus besoin
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
tu va m'attendre ici si je ne suis pas
de retour dans deux heures va au bal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cha cha cha cha sofia sera monsieur
samedi
[Rires]
que faire d'une femme est la plus belle
eau à médine on tutoie elles remettent à
moi
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
voilà
votre forme compliquer singulièrement la
vie et pourtant les fous sont moins
gênant dans la vie que les saints
d'esprit
alors lui crèche malfi et eu l'échec ou
non un non attendez attendez
tu aimes pas s'avouer battue tu t'es tu
aussi têtus que blonde que tu es chine
que tu es blonde
comment ai-je pu mettre au monde une
femme semblables moi mais vous n'êtes
pas aussi peur du tout sérieusement si
je te rencontrer par hasard et que je ne
sois pas ton père te plaît ne pensez pas
que les choses sont déjà suffisamment
compliqué oui père c'est vrai je le
proclame
si je veux rencontrer dans la rue je me
retournerai sur vous après trois pas
bien servi la naissance et moi je me
retournerai sur toi tout de suite vu
l'indécence et je te suivrai pas réduit
le passage des ans et dont désagréable
et inhumain cessé d'invoquer dû à tout
instant alex ans mais pourquoi me
suis-je dopage en plus fidèles
représentent il y as raison père s'il
vous entendre serait le premier pape à
être excommunié ex que lui y es tu
encore çà et là ça prétend que je vais
être excommunié jusqu'au but n'est pas
requis par mois
votre sainteté un malheur un grand
malheur espace tine il y à une heure un
passant a aperçu un cadavre flottant le
long du tibre
c'était le corps d'un homme tué à coups
de dague il a été repêché sans toi ce
plus bas et votre sainteté
c'était juin c'est pas vrai
office
c'est pas possible montrer les mois où
est il witty
autre
oh
jurant tous ce soir de venger ce crime
atroce
[Musique]
comme on le voit je n'avais pas le temps
de m'ennuyer je n'avais même plus le
temps de me scandalise et je me
demandais parfois ce que faisait dieu
mais dieu était bien le dernier souci le
monde possesseurs nous aimions le duc de
garder plus que tout au monde
tout à l'heure ils ont volontiers cette
fois la papauté pour le rendre à la vie
dieu nous a punis de pêcher à présent il
n'y aura plus de 25 une chance faveur le
concubinage de simoni les choses
mondaines ne franchiront plus notre
seuil nous rétablirons la célérité du
culte sacré et nous transformerons
complètement le vatican enfin le tube de
grady ne méritait pas une grosse
l'afrique comme c'était mon fort n'est
ce pas 13
mais dites moi c'est bien joli tout ça
et comment va-t-on subsister mon père a
fort mal dormi ça l'a toujours vendu
scrupules jusqu'à l'excès mais rassurez
vous ces larmes seront sèches
avant les vêtements de mon frère il
était si proche de moi et si beau si
brillant il semblait temps mais oui
c'est un très grand malheur ces douars
tué jure que tu trouveras son meurtrier
wibert jeune je le trouverai mettons et
pau sorte
pourquoi ne participe-t-il pas notre
peine c'est difficile à croire permet ce
meurtre lui a fait peur il est reparti
pour pesaro ce matin à l'aube quoi
partie mais tu ne m'as pas prévenu non
mais t'es jeune t'es pas prévenu j'ai
toujours eu une certaine affection pour
sporza personnes la connaissez mais plus
les peaux atlantique
je ne pourrais pas supporter seul
pouvoir perdu goofy vous le retrouverez
pernes
mais vous ou d'eau auprès de dieu vous
croyez bien en dieu qu'en voiture et moi
je crois en dieu
que penses-tu dont j'avais moi même
retiré au couvent et prier pour l'âne de
joie je te suivrai lucrèce
moi aussi j'ai grand besoin de prier
j'ai horreur de la tragédie c'est bien
tombé
lemay spéciales et vous n'êtes pas seuls
pères vous avez à notre fils et qu'il
revient de pleurer à cause de vous et
puis nous savons que les vrais hommes
n'aiment pas pleurer de voir leurs
femmes
oui c'est vrai
lucrèce ans son couvent s'alourdissait
elle avait accouché très prochainement
d'un enfant qui légalement serait le
fils de sporza
et le nouveau césar mais ford a regimbé
[Musique]
oh
pendant ce temps le chef très chrétiens
de l'église catholique le pape essayé de
reprendre goût à la vie terrestre
1 aidé par ses arrêts par lui même ils y
parvenaient sans trop de peine
e
aussitôt consoler sa parade contre ce
faux seins fut foudroyante de cynisme et
d'impudence dont j'accuse transforme ça
d'avoir abandonné à la solitude m'a
ravissante fille et de ne pas avoir
rempli revers elle ses devoirs dépôt
comment at il pu d'ailleurs regardez mes
seigneurs ont regardé regardez ce frêle
agneaux cette beauté abandonné par cet
étrange et je demande d'annulation
excusez moi votre graff votre grâce
jure-t-elle n'avoir jamais été touché
par son époux et légère
ce sont les to peer est parfaitement
c'est de la douleur la douleur la route
ont mené là elle sera mangée crue
votre sainteté je demande la parole
je profite de votre réunion très sain
conseiller pour vous demander
l'autorisation de quitter votre noble
habille cette pourpre cardinalice dont
je ne me sens pas assez digne
depuis longtemps je me savais n'est pour
être un homme séculier et plus
précisément un homme d'armes
je sentais mon bras plus capable que ma
foi de défendre le saint trône la mort
de mon frère
le très cher join me permet à présent de
m'exprimer je tiens à vendre à l'église
et à vous ces terres qui m'ont été
attribué en tant que cardinal ses
châteaux ses possessions que mes
aptitudes spirituel nommé rythme il vous
sera loisible de m'en donner d'autres si
vous estimez que mes capacités
militaires les mérites
je renonce à mon cardinalat
sachez faire simple si bien les choses
beaucoup mieux ainsi n'est ce pas
l'humilité de notre cher frère césar
borgia nous émeut mais elle ne me
surprend pas si votre sainteté ne s'y
opposent pas nous sommes d'accord pour
rendre notre frère à la vie séculière
qui visiblement lui convient poko
beaucoup plus que celle de notre pieuse
on s'est entendu mon fils nous vous
rendons à cette vallée de larmes
[Musique]
oh
oui
on
moi
on voit
le seigneur leonard green j est arrivé
votre grâce à wii
tu vas voir césar c'est peut-être le
plus grand peintre de notre époque ils
viennent florence c'est ce pauvre sporza
qui m'en a parlé
bon je vais te laisser la peinture ne
m'intéresse pas c'est ainsi mais
nombreuses à messieurs babines chez quel
plaisir de vous voir
je suis vraiment désolé de ce retard
mais il était due à cet incident cet
incident est très beau madame
monseigneur mon frère césar alors
montrez moi les plans vous avez fait
asseyez-vous près de moi et j'en poste
la peinture magazine 10h que je préfère
[Applaudissements]
ce profil est admirable
quel sûreté le dessin vous aimez les
gens n'est ce pas là nardo qu'elle
chargeait devant rentrer
messire messire leonardo d'amitié caisse
là c'est une catapulte
c'est un système nouveau que j'ai
inventé vous voyez en déplaçant le
mécanisme de fermeture et en suivant les
lois de la balistique
on peut obtenir une trajectoire
absolument précises et d'une portée de
plus de 900 pieds vous vous y connaissez
en balistique et ça qu'est ce que c'est
c'est une machine à mitrailler qui peut
envoyer simultanément et sous le même
angle 10 à 12 décharge de plombs vous
êtes l'homme qu'il me faut mais sierre
davinci à partir de maintenant vous êtes
mon grand ingénieur et m'ont conseillé
de guerre
monseigneur je suis peintre je ne suis
pas homme de guerre tous ces cons qui ne
sont que des distractions des rêveries
des hypothèses est que croyez vous que
soit la guerre sinon une énorme rêverie
messire davinci nous allons rêver
ensemble et pour longtemps croyez le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi
pas trop triste d'avoir quitté la
pourpre cardinalice citerai le nouveau
roi de france louis xii veut se
débarrasser de sa femme refuse le breton
je lui ai promis l'annulation en échange
d'un mariage avec une princesse du sang
ce sera tout un époux doit aller en
france
quand le plus tôt possible pendant son
absence je marierai du grès alphonse
darragi qui c'est celui là un petit
bâtard canut et ridicule pour l'ukraine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
tu
/
key
alphonse d'aragon
[Musique]